Rebecca Mader whoa all right so only on
TV can the Wicked Witch be smoking hot
like this is it the joy of television
brings us this yeah so once upon a time
has its own breed of fans day you guys
are amazing as soon as a character is
introduced they immediately name the
fandom they immediately and you have
your pretties I do so what is the
interaction with your pretties like a
daily basis daily basis yeah I do
something at least once every day
whether it's snapchat Facebook Instagram
or Twitter I've got to do a little bit
of something just to connect I love
social media and have you ever been
given a script or a storyline and
thought oh they're not gonna like that
oh yeah well most of them when I I mean
when I stole a baby strangled a child
kill Rumplestiltskin son and then went
oops I mean there's been some really
ghastly awful very very wicked things
that I've done where I read the script
I'm like I'm gonna get a lot of hate
tweets for that but that means they love
you
sweetly yes which is very odd to be sort
of praised for being abusive but I'll
take it
thank you and our people do people still
give you a tissue for Charlotte's nose
bleeds from lost yeah I don't talk about
it when when I was on loss and they
asked me to come back and I went walk
for another nosebleed and they're like
no to have sex with so I'm like hey on
the way when's the flight thank you
I'll let the nose Glee's go what are you
guys into what do you what if you got to
walk around comic-con what would you
want to go see Game of Thrones and I'm
oh my god I am halfway through and just
knee-deep in stranger things it's
amazing yeah oh my god it's so wicked I
love it where do you guys stand on
spoilers not only just for your own
shows but for shows you're fans of do
you read them I hate spoilers like when
Game of Thrones is on if I'm out of the
country I have to stay off Twitter I
don't I don't I love the element of
surprise I don't like knowing I don't
even like knowing on my own show if the
executives start to talk about you know
five episodes now my lalala
laughs I don't I don't want to know I
like staying in the prison yeah I've had
fans guess really big things before like
you know I killed made merry and
pretended to be her and got pregnant by
Robin Hood as you do and I mean it's
like a Tuesday in it and all right oh my
god when they told Mike the fans are
gonna hate me they're gonna kill me all
the outlaw Queen I mean they're all
going to hate me they were going to come
after me and then yeah I was right yeah
I like going to conventions because
that's where you really meet the best
fans the people that just really go for
it I mean that's I mean it's wicked I
love doing commit I mean you know you
sit at a we think I'm a bit tired and
then you look up and there's someone
dressed as you what's better than that I
mean it's just bonkers or sometimes I
get like little girls that addressed all
up in green and it's so sweet and people
put so much thought into it I just I
love it do you think Selina would
continue in her path of redemption well
I know the answer to that and I can't
say it which is really boring we're
halfway through shootings episode 602 so
I know the direction that I'm going on
but I mean you knowing Adam and Eddie
three episodes from now I could turn
around and be green and rip your head
off so anything's possible and once upon
a time but I really really like the arc
that they've written for my character
over the past few episodes and I'm
really enjoying the relationship between
Zelena and Regina and you're going to
see some really really really cool stuff
between the sisters this season I mean I
was actually doing it well while cuts
and turns I wasn't doing it with Lana I
was working with Lana that would be
weird because we're sisters and
yeah it's a Disney show salon or line
you're going to give Bruce a stroke yes
salon and I were working on a sister
scene at one o'clock this morning and I
just got in so it's a miracle I'm still
awake but there's really good stuff to
come with the sisters thank you
this questions for Rebecca I know
recently you got to work with the
Barbara Hershey and beaches is like my
favorite movie of all time
oh I love it so much any of any feel
it's just so good but um I know Lana got
to work with her a lot in the past
seasons and you how was that dynamic and
how was the chemistry with you guys and
how was it like to just work with
Barbara Hershey hashtag blessed
it was the episode 519 Sisters where I
finally got my mom and I got to you know
work out all the issues with her giving
me up and to have that kind of closure
was absolutely amazing that episode
really just blew my socks off and the
three of us just working to go in
Barbara Hershey is just a legend and she
was my mum I'm like well how did I get
here and I mean there's the scenes that
we did was so moving and sending her off
to heaven and the three of us just get
on so well in real life anyway and even
like we know before we would shoot a
scene we'd all just be holding hands and
would already be crying and telling each
other that we loved each other it was
like two days of just like weeping and
crying and like mutual like fan club it
was really one of the most special
moments of my career and I'll never
forget it
thank you do you think Selina still has
feelings for Hades even after all the
bad things he's done yeah
I'll be fine I'll be fine I mean I
killed the man that I loved
there was a really intense thing to do
but I had to save my sister's life
didn't I
but yeah it's the first time that Selina
ever really opened up her heart but you
know and love someone besides her baby
and I think she was very very hurt by
the fact that he betrayed her and he
lied to her but I think there's a little
bit of her that will always love him
because he was her first love but he
wasn't good enough for her so right now
she doesn't need a man she's gonna be a
good mummy okay thank you very much for
your question
you